today I teach at taught us about a place
called Africa
[Applause]
you say our Mama's come from Queens over
there
that means that we
royalty
I don't
[Music]
want you to love me afternoon
I need me a wife
even if we have to part you and me let's
have one heart
[Music]
you I'll write you every day
nothing but that can keep me from it
you must ain't got no Kinfolk around
these parts all I had was my sister
she was the only one ever loved me
it's time for you to see the world
there's gonna be some changes made put
it on this ain't me hush we need to look
like we belong let's see the smile and
come oh sweet and loving God
[Applause]
hi
dear Celie we are more than just kings
and queens
we are at the center of the universe